what's up guys bang-bang fake news
welcome to lunch money well while she's
trying to get rich through some she's
trying to get a lunch money right I'm
here with the beautiful intelligent play
Tamara Nova who has on a Canadian tuxedo
fragrant yeah you smell like trash poop
captain I don't know what smells worse
trash or cat poop but that's what you
smell like today just kidding don't
forget lunch money is now sponsored by
block five I've got three products you
can buy and sell crypto currencies you
can deposit crypto and get a u.s. dollar
loan or you can earn up to eight point
six percent interest in an
interest-bearing account it's a
no-brainer I'm an investor I'm a user go
deposit crypto war dollars and earn up
to eight point six percent interest
click on the link in the description or
use block fight comm slash lunch money
get money get paid miss cat poop what's
going out to zombie markets oh yeah i'ma
get in trouble later I don't care I
don't care today bang bang
zombie markets what's up that was
violence that was violence so this
economist is saying that he's not just
worried about zombie companies but he's
also worried about zombie markets okay
he's not some economist Muhammad Ali
who's one of the probably most well
known economist in the world who goes on
CNBC all time he's talking about the
zombie markets anything specific that he
said in there you go on CNBC all the
time doesn't mean you're smart
I didn't say smart I said well-known
facts matter what's going on what did he
say about this is jambe markets okay he
said I think we've got to be careful
about zombie markets or not there yet
but we're starting to get close first of
all what is a zombie market well as ahhm
be is basically like you ever seen in
the movies where they just kind of lurch
forward and it seems like they're just
doing whatever the the whole group is
doing but there's not actually any
intelligence or conscious going on right
now there's like on all walk on the
street that's what a mark a zombie
market is zombie market is something
that basically is just
it looks like it's going up but it's
actually dead inside right and that's
kind of what we're seeing right now is
we're seeing the Federal Reserve pump
stocks to the moon they are just pumping
stocks no trash or cat poop
either one don't worry I mean you know
what else smells like trash is the stock
market right now it's going up but the
economic data underlying these the
economy is absolutely falling off a
cliff and hopefully it's going to come
back as they open up some of these
various locations and economies but at
the same time companies are still having
to report their earnings and so we saw I
think it was American Airlines reported
they were revenue was down 90 percent of
bookings were down 90 percent you saw
Hertz they go bankrupt right they're
literally selling equity to investors of
a bankrupt continues to go up because
they are pumping it with liquidity so
basically the whole idea is the stock
price is based on two things it's the
value of the asset right - will stock
itself what is it worth and then what
currency denominated it so right now if
you did nominate every single stock in
dollars over the last ten days every
single stock in the stock market is up
every single one it's not one stock that
has gone down last right in terms of on
a net basis if you de nominate those
same stocks in let's say Bitcoin or in
gold most of them are not up right
especially if you extend that outs like
a 90-day period or two the beginning of
this year and so what ends up happening
is the currency in which you value or to
nominate the stock market in really
matters the US dollar is there just
printing and printing in printing did
you see today what they're saying
there's gonna be another one trillion
dollars
no actually what they want to do is I
want to print another trillion dollars
and for an infrastructure bill they want
to improve the roads and the bridges and
do all this kind of stuff which by the
way in the past doing things like this
does stimulate the economy right they're
gonna inject another billion dollar
another trillion dollars into the
economy what's a great way to do that
well let's go build [ __ ] right like okay
make sense
the problem though ends
being at the bottom 50% of the economy
those people are not seeing any of this
that's why I coming out of 2008-2009
they printed hundreds of billions of
dollars but actually there was no high
level of inflation the money came in to
the top right with all of the monetary
policy but it never actually went down
trickle-down economics doesn't work and
so what ends up happening is it just got
sucked up by people at the top of the
economy and you never got the high
levels of consumer inflation stopping
money remember when we first started
this and you were like I just print
whatever you want no I didn't you
convert never you've converted well I
feel like we've converted somebody to a
new religion you're okay so Amazon Jeff
Bezos is the new Mark Zuckerberg you
know why why he's willing to testify
before the house to answer questions
about the tech companies competitive
practices on this very lunch money
we have debated whether or not Jeff
Bezos and Amazon is anti-competitive
something awfully that's what I miss
this is a great move by Jeff Bezos you
know why Jeff Bezos has one advantage
over Mark Zuckerberg I'm huge Mark
Zuckerberg fan I think he's incredibly
intelligent I think the press has got a
lot about him wrong I'm biased I worked
at Facebook but Jeff Bezos has a lot of
charisma and I think that when Jeff
Bezos goes in front of these politicians
I actually think that he will disarm a
lot of them compared to somebody like a
Mark Zuckerberg who is much more robotic
and has much less personality Bezos I
believe is going to be able to kind of
quell some of the fears I he doesn't do
a lot of media appearances and he also
doesn't he keeps it low-key I I don't
think I've ever actually heard him speak
except in that really old TED talk he
did he just has this kind of like aw
shucks approach to the way that he does
a lot of those presentations and I think
that he's very very thoughtful obviously
he is the founder of Amazon the most
viable company in the world
so did he voluntarily like volunteer to
do this well they're definitely they've
been definitely trying to figure out can
they get him in front of some sort of
congressional hearing or House hearing
and it sounds like he's now saying okay
he'll he'll participate right so we'll
see look and I think this may not just
be him this may be a number of yeah yeah
yeah and and they basically they
threatened to subpoena him so it's kind
of like a hey you're gonna have to do it
anyway so you might as well come willing
write a hearing like this is it just to
gather information or can Amazon
actually be disciplined in some way well
I don't think that this is an Amazon
hearing this is a tech CEO here where
they're gonna have multiple people come
in
it's definitely right now kind of a
fact-finding mission that will then kind
of influence do they want to move
forward with certain things they also
will bring non tech CEOs right cuz
they'll bring the other side so much
people will go up and say these
companies are competitive or
anti-competitive their monopolies break
them up you know yadda yadda whatever in
my mind
Jeff Bass was gonna go he's gonna talk
and I think he'll do a pretty good job
and for people like you who say hey I've
never really heard him talked that much
I think people walk away but hey you
know what like that guy seems like a
pretty reasonable dude we'll see I'm
very curious to hear yesterday do you
think that he wears shirt and tie and a
suit or do you think he shows up like he
did in Sun Valley with his guns out
showing him like Terminator style
I think gums out I think he wears a suit
in time really it's a good it's a let's
make him bet on this very show okay what
do you want to bet I win you know why
cuz it's it's a government hearing he's
not gonna [ __ ] over this guns out
but I'm saying he's not gonna wear a
suit and tie yes he is okay well you
wanna bet no time if I am right you have
to come on the show and you have to say
Anthony's a genius and always right okay
or if I win you have to come on the show
and say Paulina is a chess champion and
I am a sore loser
deal book it you know I won that one
all righty mobile outage what's going on
with the DDoS it was a DDoS
yesterday because I was very upset so
yesterday around 4:00 p.m. I called my
mom and there was no ringtone it was
like that's weird I thought it was my
phone restarted my phone called her
again no ringtone what the hell is going
on
call my dad ringtone so it's not my
phone it must be her phone and then I
get no call back I don't get anything
meanwhile Anthony and my mom are texting
and I'm like wait a second
Wi-Fi oh well I was like why is she not
calling me but she's texting with him
and now well she likes me more than you
but good so today she texted me and said
t-mobile customers won't say that
t-mobile had an outage yesterday and she
has t-mobile so there's a DDoS attack
that took down t-mobile ones up the DDoS
attack is a denial of service attack so
basically it in very kind of lame and
over generalized terms if you're a
computer scientist don't get mad at how
simple I'm making the salad but
basically the way that computers
communicate with each other technology
communicates is there's an input and an
output
yeah right so like think of it as a
phone call would be I call you you can
call me but if I have 15 people or a
thousand or 10,000 people all calling
your number all day long simultaneously
you can't use your phone right so that's
a very generalized way to show like what
happens is basically you get a bunch of
things computers out there in the world
to all point at one either server a
website whatever it is and you just
literally denial-of-service try just
over and over and over again pinging it
are you sure it was an attack cuz
all right that was weird we just got
ddosed attacked sorry no we did it
he has monkeytoes and he disconnected
the internet it was a DDoS attack okay
so what I was trying to say took me off
the air is that an eye sensor you is
that the company didn't say they were oh
my god today is a good day I'm about to
disconnect your life so t-mobile didn't
say they were attacked t-mobile said
this was the result of a widespread
routing issue so of course what else
would you say what are you gonna be like
oh yeah we got attack that we didn't
know how to repeal the attack because
I've seen it literally there's a bunch
of things circulating on the internet
where all the attacks came you can
measure this stuff if you go on Twitter
right now and type in DDoS you'll see
all of the charts where everyone was
attacking all right so when max when we
go read the Internet when we get off the
air I'll attack him and then let's see
if he says he was just having a
widespread outage issue no he'll say she
attacks me pray for me okay for me I was
going on private schools your name is
Clarence and you went to the private
school if you know what reference that
is shout out why are you in such a weird
mood today I can't eat mile Eminem
what's up your real name is Clarence and
you went to the Babbitt school go ahead
we work what's going on sorry I was
meditating there for a second so I
couldn't deal with you I did that I fall
asleep we work is talking to New York
City private schools about holding
classes and offices this fall is this
because like we works like oh my god we
need revenue sources it's cuz we work
when but she just
it's literally there's lighting money on
fire just light it on fire baby kwibi
and we work there distant cousins but I
mean look at the end of the day they
have a space I mean they have space
they're trying to figure how to use the
space what it tells me is that they
definitely don't think people are coming
back into the office space in at least
not to a hurt percent capacity that they
previously had and so what do you do you
are trying to be entrepreneurial and
creative and figure out what other
people would be willing to use the space
schools sure maybe I don't know maybe
I'll you know see about an office
because I can't work like this with you
here um but they also said they are
starting with private schools but they
might you know have conversations with
public schools of the public school
system would be interested in those what
they should do is teach everybody about
money little financial education and
personal responsibility go far way in
this today's world they should also
teach some English and grammar
speaking of ADHD yes yeah I wonder if I
I wonder uh I don't want to know
actually I just like me for me you liked
me for me - don't don't lie ADHD a B D
Co MP it's all the same thing
please stop talking so the first video
game based treatment for ADHD which is
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
has been approved by the US FDA the Food
and Drug Administration and this is
really interesting because this game is
prescription only aimed at children
between the ages of 8 and 12 with
certain types of ADHD and this is really
cool I think because it offers a non
drug option for kids with ADHD the first
thing when we moved to America from
Bulgaria is like literally all my
friends were taking some sort of
medication for a DD or ADHD and I was
like what is that and why and I think
that maybe before you medicate you could
try something like this well couple of
things one this is dumb why why do we
need the FDA to approve a video game
this is an overreach of government power
and it's absolute nonsense second of all
I agree that we shouldn't be drugging
our kids because literally what you're
doing is you're essentially making them
just zombies right you're literally just
drugging them into it depends what
you're using it for and how severe the
problem is but to me like I was a really
active child now I'm calm and collected
yeah I mean look I'm not a doctor right
I'm sure that they have some really
intellectual Olympics way of describing
ADHD but there's a lot of people who
also are just creative or they just
haven't entered five years old yeah well
I mean like again I just I generally
don't agree with drugging young kids
because part of the beauty of childhood
and their development is to allow them
to grow right like we live in a society
where society wants to put all of these
like kind of ball and chain on you they
want you to do what they want you to do
they don't want you to be creative they
don't want you to be hyperactive they
don't want you to go and explore and
it's because we're trying to act like
implement this control system well let
people be people we're humans is our
greatest advantage is our creativity and
our excitement listen to this
approximately four million children aged
6 to 11 are affected by ADHD the
symptoms of which include difficulty
staying focused and paying attention and
difficulty controlling behavior but if
you like you could say that pretty much
about any kid I know I don't stay
focused I don't pay attention and I
definitely don't control my behavior
lord knows but a lot of people would say
that while it's a blessing it's also a
curse so we watch the Garth Brooks
documentary on Netflix last night and
Garth Brooks says everything that's a
blessing is also a curse that's what
he's saying in fact it's true it's a
great way to look at the world by the
way there's lots of video games out
there this is the first one that's
fda-approved I have no doubt that there
are things that can help kids
concentrate more do all this kind of
stuff I just generally don't think that
drugging kids is a good idea and I
actually think that if a kid is super
rambunctious doubled down on it tripled
down on it right help them use it to
their advantage rather than say hey take
this little pill and you'll be so okay
this is kind of not related but kind of
related Neil deGrasse Tyson I was
watching an interview with him and he's
all about like encourage your kids
curiosity allow them to explore the
world and ask questions and so he was
like I was in the park and it was
raining and he saw a mom and her
son walking and it's like four-year-old
and there was a really really big puddle
he was completely wearing like boots
rain boots rain CO everything and he
just like saw that puddle and you could
tell he was about to like run into it
and she pulled him away and they walked
around the puddle so his whole idea is
like let the kid jump in because that
will give him the experience and he'll
ask questions and he'll understand more
about the worlds then if you just try to
help protect him from everything in life
I actually agree with that but also you
can see the parents that like you I'm
not cleaning my kids well I'm a Clinton
but still right it's just the fact that
like that there's two sides to each one
of these situations and you have to
decide like what are you gonna optimize
for it right and some people want to
optimize for the efficiency and
effectiveness of controlling your
children others want to literally
encourage them to be themselves and
double and triple down on it I actually
don't think either one is critical wrong
it's just what's your personal
preference right yeah
that's my take you would totally you
would let your kid like swimming just so
we're clear I would be jumping in the
puddle first and then the kid might be
allowed to do it but what's going on
celebrities zoom okay so do you guys
know cameo yes I do they can't answer me
all right so that's like when she talks
to me she ask me questions I don't
answer oops
all right what's going on cameo I mean
okay we gonna have a long conversation
after this no we ain't
I'm gonna work out go ahead I have no
pants on right now go ahead so cameo is
this website where if you pay if you
watched much money yesterday you saw
Dennis Rodman say happy birthday to
Anthony shout out to another Gemini go
ahead so basically you can go on there
you can type in a message to your
favorite celebrity and pay some money
and they will send you back a
personalized video message well now
cameo is taking it up a notch and
letting people pay up to fifteen
thousand dollars to zoom have a zoom
call with a celebrity Jeremy Piven the
guy from Entourage is
charging $15,000 for ten minutes yeah
okay charge us $20 for a video shoutout
Tony Hawk charges a thousand Bret Sabre
father oh my god a bear Brett Favre okay
I never I never I never spit on the name
of a legend like that it's a Brett favor
it's a it's charging $5,000 and and
cameo says up to four additional friends
or family can drain the cost so
technically you can like split it also
some people are only charging like $700
or 500 so that's more reasonable than
15,000 who cares about celebrities why
you got paid thousands of dollars and
speaking of which our friend over here
just this morning got on cameo that's
why you say it enough
who cares for 50 bucks Polina told me I
should do it so I'm on cameo now you
want me to say wild [ __ ] just go on
there pay me 50 bucks I'll say whatever
you want wait so I don't actually have
to win that bet I can just type it and
pay some 50 bucks and you'll say pullian
as a chess champion she is always right
your fee will be much higher no all
right guys that's it for lunch money
today well while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
her lunch money right hopefully when you
come back tomorrow Polina will still be
here but we'll see you smell like cat
poop
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a u.s. dollar loan you can earn up
to eight point six percent interest on
an interest-bearing account or you can
buy and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so
I'm going in the description say thanks
to the folks that block by subscribe to
our channel like the video annoy playing
in the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends